hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today were gonna be
looking at a nice little in-game
position where both sides have the same
colored bishop the light square bishop
in this particular game and one side has
a pawn looking to push it to the
eighth-ranked you cannot checkmate your
opponent with only a bishop so it is
important that white pushes the pawn up
to this eighth rank and on black side
the board it's knowing that he can't win
his only goal is to try to keep his
opponent from promoting this pond so
he's gonna make sure that his bishop is
stopping this entire diagonal right here
so that's kind of game we have going on
it is White's move on so we're gonna be
looking at a few positions on how white
can successfully push this pawn up the
board one thing you'll notice is if the
bishop the light square bishop can come
up here to b7 that would be extremely
beneficial it would stop the attack that
this lighter bishop here on f3 has they
can't have in exchange because then the
King could just take here on b7 and so
White's gonna be looking to bring his
bishop here to d3 and then come over
here to a6 and then eventually here to
b7 I do recognize that the light square
bishop we come up here to f5 and then c8
and b7 but we're gonna be looking at the
line if he comes here to d3 and then
you'll see this play out in some other
scenarios that we're going to look at so
the first one is going to be this pawn
or this Bishop here to d3 and this is
blocking off the King coming over to b5
trying to stop this and there's not a
lot that the light square bishop here on
f3 can do to stop this who's just going
to come to d5 allowing our bishop to
come up here to a6 and the next move is
gonna be b7 here at no point can this
Bishop really move away because if it
comes off this long diagonal then all of
a sudden it's very easy game for white
white pushes forward with pawn to b7 and
then this light square bishop can no
longer attack that so this bishops kind
of forced to just come back here to f3
or some other square on this diagonal to
try to hold on to this and then Bishop
to b7 now it's not
quite as easy as exchanging off because
this bishops never going to exchange off
the board but he could come here to e2
saying as soon as you move I'm going to
essentially take your place on board as
that's okay
we can now bring our Bishop down here to
g2 and he's gonna try to take our place
up here to a6 but here's the decisive
move it's Bishop to f1 it says you can't
come to be seven because the king could
just take it right here and so you're
going to essentially have to take my
bishop right here and then I'm going to
push up and you can no longer stop me
and then I'm going to promote my queen
up here to b8 now do recognize that the
bishop could come up here to c8 if your
opponent does play this just keep in
mind you need to play an in-between move
it's gonna be very bad if you take this
bishop right away because then you'll
just lose your pawn and that defeats the
entire purpose but if you just play
Bishop to e2 kind of a waiting move now
your opponent is forced to make a bad
move he has to stop this pawn pushing
forward he can't come here to b7 because
now your king takes and still protecting
the pawn right here
can't really come down here to a6 cuz
then the bishops just gonna take here on
a6 so all now is gonna be looking to
play something around Bishop to h3 but
then the pawn just pushes forward so
really is best move although it's not
really a great move is to go ahead and
take here on F 1 and then the pawns
gonna push forward pawn here to b7
doesn't matter where the bishop goes now
let's say Bishop to G to pawn pushes up
here to b8 and we'll go ahead and get a
queen on board and this is a pretty easy
in game if you're not super familiar
with it
just make sure your king and queen and
never get on a light square this light
square bishop is now completely useless
on board should be a very very easy game
so that's kind of the the basic setup if
we were to look at it in this position
it's not always this easy so we are
gonna look at a few other examples and
by the end of it we're gonna look at
maybe the most complex example but I
think it will make a lot more sense
as we kind of start from this position
next position we're gonna be looking at
is a little bit trickier now but does
follow the same logic that we've talked
about and I do like following the same
line of thinking because there's a lots
of ways that you can actually checkmate
your opponent get your pawn to this
eighth rank right here but I think if
you follow the same structure in all of
your in games it's much easier to
remember one train of thought than
trying to just come up with lots of
different variations so if you remember
from the first position the King was up
here on f7 so we're gonna try to be
getting our King up here to f7 now we
have a couple moves with the bishop we
really want this Bishop on g7 to no
longer be on this long diagonal right
here that's kind of the key so that we
can bring our King up here to f6 and
then f7 so we have a couple ways to try
to do this the best move is really
Bishop here to g5 now if we started with
something like Bishop to f6 tried to
force the bishop the bishops not going
to take more than likely we're gonna see
King up here to h6 and then Bishop to g5
forcing the King back to h5 doesn't
really have any other option and then
let's say Bishop to e7 so we're kind of
in the same position except now it's
blacks move okay so if it's blacks move
he may play King up here to h6 trying to
be aggressive as possible
Bishop to f6 forcing the bishop to move
a little bit different position
Bishop to f8 and then a bishop down here
c3 we have to make way for our King to
come up the board here but then Bishop
back here g7 we haven't really changed
too much we can't take the bishop on f7
because then the King will just
recapture okay so let's try something
different bishop down here to d2 and
then King h5 and then Bishop up here g5
now as you can see if we come back to
the very beginning all we had to do was
just play Bishop to g5 but I do like to
kind of talk about you know why would
you not play f6 I think it gets us to
the same point but just go ahead and
play you know Bishop here to g5 first
now there's there's two things that
black can do here you know we that the
King can't move he just doesn't have any
legal moves and so really
we're gonna be looking at Bishop up here
to h8 and then Bishop here to f8 if he
tries to come you know anywhere else
let's say Bishop to d4 all of those are
going to lose to Bishop on f6 this kind
of blocks the threats makes it easy for
us to push up the board with pawn to g7
so that's definitely going to be bad he
has the option Bishop here to h8
definitely the worst of the options
simply because now Bishop to f6 loses
the game for black he can't come to g7
because then we'll just take the bishop
right here and then if he were to take
our Bishop then we're going to take back
with our king so the only real option
that he has is to bring his bishop to f8
and so this is where we're going to
start pushing up our King this is what
we talked about we want to get our King
here to f7 because that's what we're
used to seeing
we could see King here to a g4 we could
see lots of variations it's not gonna
stop the fact that our king is gonna be
coming up here to s7 but this does add a
little bit of pressure on us we need to
make sure that our Bishop here on g5 is
safe so we can't play King up here to f7
first we're gonna play Bishop down here
to e3 and then just see you know where
our opponent goes it's it's gonna be
pretty bad if he plays King to f3 tries
to chase us because then just King up
here to f7 we're gonna be pushing our
pawn to g7 and then you know we're going
to promote right here there's no way to
really stop that on board he can't play
Bishop to g7 we take you can't play
Bishop here to h6 because then we'll
just take it with our Bishop right here
so that's gonna be a bad way to go about
it his other option would let's say
Bishop to b4 so if we come back that one
square if he plays Bishop to b4 then we
play King to f7 there are some other
ways you can attack this but the King to
f7 is the same position that we're used
to seeing so this has allows us to
continue our same approach Bishop to c3
he needs to stop this long diagonal so
that the pawn can't push forward with g7
so now we can
continue what we're doing we're trying
to get our Bishop here to h6 and then up
here to g7 so let's do that we played
Bishop to h6 and then he plays King to
f5 he could have doubled around with his
dark squared Bishop but it wouldn't have
really done anything he still needs to
stay on this long diagonal then we
played Bishop to g7 forcing the bishop
to move he can't take our Bishop because
then we'll through recapture that's
gonna be an easy win for us so he's kind
of forced to come over here to d2 says
as soon as you move I'm going to take
your place on board and that's exactly
what we saw in the first position so
Bishop down here to b2 and then Bishop
h6 and then we have that in-between move
that forces him to essentially take our
Bishop and then we can go ahead and push
forward so after Bishop takes on c1 they
would push forward to pawn to g7 and
then the next move is gonna be promoting
here to g8 so nice little tactic to make
sure that we can get our King to the
position we want and then push our pawn
up and promote on the eighth-ranked the
last position we're gonna be looking at
is the most complex synchrony in game
but I think the other positions we've
looked at will help us better understand
how to approach this and if you were
looking on Wikipedia this is the
position specifically in 1856 the
century knee actually published and he
kind of went through how you can win as
white by the end of this hopefully
everyone is kind of a master now the the
dark square bishop here for white is in
kind of a trickier place than before you
know earlier we had the bishop over here
we could easily just come to a7 there
was no way to really block that from
here it's gonna take a few moves we
can't come here to just be six because
the king would take that right away okay
we're gonna have to kind of come around
let's say Bishop to h4 then over here to
f2 and then up here to a7 that's kind of
the intended plan but black is able to
stop that because after Bishop down here
to h4 then King to b6 you can see him
starting to stop the attack okay Bishop
to f2 and then King to a6 this stops it
right here now white does have a really
good move on board if you haven't seen
this position I could
recommend that you pause and see if you
could find whites best move in this
position so hopefully you've taken some
time if you wanted to see if you could
find the best move but the best move is
Bishop to c5 and if you were to try
something else let's say Bishop to d4
the goal with c5 it we kind of look at
it and we'll kind of come back to d4 but
the goal is Bishop to e7 and then d8 and
then d7 really blocking off the dark
square bishop for blacks opportunity to
stop the pond pushing forward to b8 so
if we do come back and say let's say
Bishop to d4 okay Bishop to d6 really
stop say if you are playing as black
keep in mind this is what you should be
looking out for you're gonna try to be
coming here to d6 now if white were to
try Bishop to f6 getting ready to come
up here to d8 okay King to b6 Bishop to
d8 and then King to c6 and then where
does white come he really can't do
anything Bishop to e7 if he tries to
kind of stop his opponents get him off
this long diagonal okay it's pretty easy
you could just bring his bishop back
here to H - he's not forced to take this
bishop right here and the bishop would
really like to come down here to c5 and
up here to a7 but as you can see can't
come down here the King's going to take
and so he's gonna have to make another
attempt to swing around the board so all
in all that's not the best way to go
about it instead he needs to play Bishop
here to c5 and we'll kind of look at why
this is so much better because now I'll
say Bishop to f4 I'm trying to stop it
okay Bishop to e7 this is what we talked
about looking to come up here to d8 and
then c7 King to b6 we looked at this
before Bishop up here to d8 keen to c6
but here is the main difference on board
and that is Bishop to g5 and it doesn't
matter where your opponent is he could
be here on g3 you know he could be here
on e5 either way you're going to bring
your Bishop next to them and kind of
them to do something now that they can't
just take right here because then you're
gonna promote here on b8
so we know that's not going to be the
way they're going to go about it but
instead of you essentially are gaining a
tempo here because let's say they come
back to g3
okay perfect now you can come down here
to be to e3 and now they can't stop you
before the king had that extra move to
come over here to b6 but he can no
longer stop you and do that and so then
we continue our normal game plan we're
gonna be looking to come up here to a7
so how do they stop it they really can't
so let's come up here to d6 okay that's
a possibility they have Bishop here to
a7 it says okay I can't really do too
much about that let's come back here to
g3 and then we see Bishop appear b8 they
can't take that right here so they're
gonna come to f2 and then we have the
Bishop down here to h2 and this is all
from the various situations we've been
looking at forcing your opponent's kind
of come up here to a7 and then we have
the last move that kind of brings it all
together and that is the Bishop down
here to g1 saying you want to replace
this on b8 you can't cuz then our King
would just take you right here we're
forcing you kind of a nice deflection to
come back take the bishop right here or
we're going to take you on a 7 and then
after they take then you can come up
here to b8 and promote to the Queen so
as we come back you can see really nice
way as we want to bring our bishop over
here to a7 to kind of move around the
board to eventually force their Bishop
to waste a move so that we can bring our
Bishop over here to a7 and their King
does not have time to stop us so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
this definitely doesn't come up all too
often but it's always good to know
especially if you have the pawn and the
bishop how to go about getting the win
and if you're playing on the opposite
side how to kind of stop your opponent
from do
do keep in mind this only works if the
bishops are on the same colored square
if one side is on the light color the
other sides on the dark color there's no
way that they can kind of interact so
you can't force them to to go anywhere
because they just never touched and it
is also important that the pawn is not
below kind of this fifth rank here
you're not gonna be able to push this up
the entire board thank you so much for
watching the video if you'd like to
practice this in game and we'll have a
link in the description below if you're
on youtube they'll take you to the
website there's multiple positions that
you may want to practice and this goes
for all the in games that I have on the
website there are practice boards that
you can actually go in and try this out
for yourself make sure that you have
mastered this there's a lot of chess in
games that you need to know this is just
one of them but feel free check that
link below go the website and see if you
have mastered that if you have feel free
to leave me a comment below let me know
that you have done that if there's other
videos you like me to make on in-game
tactics
feel free to let me know that as well
but thank you guys so much for watching
the video if you haven't already please
subscribe like the video and I'll see
you guys next time thanks for watching
you